do you weight train you just seem
naturally strong and like thicker
jointed it's true yeah it's true I when
we did the one very beginner because I'm
a very beginner of Jiu Jitsu class
together
and um yeah as I mentioned then uh but
if people missed it uh Alexis freakishly
strong I think I was born genetically to
hug people oh like Costello yeah exactly
you guys have a certain similarity he
had wrists like you know it's like you
and Jocko and Costello have these like
wrists and and elbows that are super
thick you know and then when you look
around you see tremendous variation you
know some people will have like the the
um wrist uh width of a whippet or Woody
Allen and then other people like you or
Jocko or you know there's this one uh
Jocko video or thing on GQ or something
Have you seen the comments on Jocko
these are the best
um the comments I love the comments on
YouTube because occasionally they're
funny
um the best is uh when chalk was born
the doctor looked at his uh parents and
said it's a man
it's like Chuck Norris type comments
yeah oh yeah those are great um that's
what I miss about Rogan being on YouTube
with the full-length episodes